the 15th annual women's leadership
conference is coming to the mgm grand
conference center phyllis james with the
foundation for women's leadership and
empowerment joining us this morning to
talk about this incredible event 15
years yes heather it's been quite a
journey but we are so happy to have made
it we've educated thousands of women and
men and men the end men so uh we're so
happy and we've got a great program this
year talk to me about that program
phyllis what is it that people can
expect if they're going to be coming to
the conference it's august 7th and 8th
yes okay and so we know that this time
after the pandemic is when so many
people are reconsidering their life path
and their careers and everybody's heard
about the great resignation yeah so uh
some people are saying what should i do
am i in the right place and so we have
speakers who are going to talk about
finding your inspiration uh are you
living your life in the front row seats
are you living it from the balcony
interesting and another thing that we
know people are concerned about is
mental health and stress and it seems
that people are at an all-time high in
stress in the workplace etc well we have
a speaker dr romy mooshtock who has been
a pioneer in mental health and wellness
in the workplace and she's going to help
people deal with burnout wow yes so uh
and we have another speaker who's going
to talk about harmonizing the demands of
work life
and home life and community life so
important and i use the term harmonize
because
there's no such thing as balance that's
what the experts now tell us okay so the
new word is harmonize how do you get
things to meld together i like that word
yes and that does feel good and i think
like you you hit on with the pandemic i
think so many people have just become so
much more self-aware or aware that
something needs to change but maybe
don't know what it is so it sounds like
this might be a good avenue to kind of
move people in the right direction yes
and kind of refocus
uh your inspiration and where you think
you're going our theme this year is
master your dash okay the dash referring
to the time you're given on this planet
and so how do you
decide to
make your life count for something how
do you make a positive life and legacy
for those around you and those who come
after you wonderful and really quick
before we go because i know we're
running out of time it is august 7th and
8th there are still there's still
availability oh absolutely we will take
registrants day of conference excellent
okay so folks you heard it right here on
channel 8 you know where to go august
7th and 8th phyllis thank you so much
for joining us thank you heather for
having me this is going to be an
incredible another incredible event 15
years thank